welcome everyone i appreciate the
opportunity to talk to you today about
the the work we've been doing in
strawberry i
arrived at university of davis uh
california davis
uh in 2015
and uh took over the strawberry breeding
and genetics program
a very long uh history very famous
program that's created a tremendous
number of important commercially
important cultivars
and i i came from uh really a background
in
in working in hybrid crops uh hybrid
sunflower and some others
and so strawberry was a really new
experience for me and the occupy genome
in particular
posts several unique technical
challenges i'll
discuss with you the program started in
1927
and it's been a source of 73 cultivars
these cultivars are have been really
transformative
in in change strawberry production not
only in california but the us and the
world
and uh provide some metrics about that
uh so i continue to be involved in in
creating
cultivars for the industry and
we have uh quite an amazing
story around that is we have a global
reach we have
international partners and the cultivars
are grown
around the world really and so it's
quite a
an amazing business within an academic
enterprise as a way to think about it
but we work very closely with several
different partners in the industry when
i came into strawberry five years ago
there had really been at davis uh almost
no work on on really the genetics or
genomics of strawberry
and so our industry was uh really eager
to have
a modernization of of the research
program
uh and really as people have described
it to me to bring us into the 21st
century
so that was a lot of of the initiatives
that i started
so just to give you an idea here uh
strawberry's a
really strange beast it was uh it's the
result it's only 300 years old really
the the
berries you see in the market today and
it uh originated
as hybrids between these two wild
species that are both
native to the new world they were
carried by explorers to europe
and they arose as spontaneous hybrids
and gardens in western europe
and so wild species have formed a lot of
the
the history and background the other
thing that's uh that's
unique about it is that both of the
parents are octopoid so this is really
what's called a homoplate a homoploid
hybrid uh
so this this was a real puzzle to
untangle uh this is we published in 2019
the first
chromosome scale genome of the octopoid
i did it with my
uh close colleague patrick edgar at
michigan state
and then michael hardigan whose paper
cited here
a postdoctoral researcher in my lab has
had a really important role in
not only this but the development of the
axiom arrays that i'll be talking about
in in a little bit
so these diploids came together formed a
tetraploid
then a hexaploid then this octaploid
then we have two octaploids
hybridizing to make the strawberry that
we actually consume in the marketplace
so it's it's got a really strange
history and without the genome and and
the axiom arrays and some other tools we
really couldn't unravel that history
very well
so that's part of what all of the story
i'll tell you today
the other thing that's really remarkable
about this
this group of plants is that we see
tremendous conservation of of the
chromosome architecture across
wide genetic backgrounds phylogenetic
backgrounds
and conservation over millions of years
so very unique
uh group of plants all in the rosaceae
family the rose family
so one of the very first things we had
to have and before we
start to build the axon array i should
back up
there there was an axiom array when we
came in it was based on the diploid and
i'll talk about that briefly
but we we built a genome for
the octopoid using this culver here
called camarosa
it's the single most important
strawberry cultivar ever
developed it was grown really for about
30 years and
and probably on well over half of the
strawberry acres in the world
so really a remarkable history and story
was developed by a gentleman by the name
of roy springhurst at uc davis and his
colleagues
so we got a good genome it's got a high
gene density so that was one of the
really nice features of this
you know there's 108 000 annotated genes
but it's a
0.83 gigabase genome so it's it's fairly
small
and it's packed into 28 chromosomes
the basic chromosome number in the
diploids is seven so there's four sets
of seven chromosomes
and so this is just a plot here on the
right of the gene density and this is
basically a plot of the octaploid genome
against the diploid reference
now i don't expect you to study this eye
chart
in depth here and the the message i'm
trying to deliver with this slide is
that this is a heat map
and the red is the uh indicates the
the greatest proportion of a sub genome
so what we see in this octaloid is that
these four diploid ancestors came
together
but they had exchanges among the
chromosomes so every chromosome
in the modern plant is a mosaic of the
four diploids
it's really strange so you think of this
you have four genomes come together
it's almost as if they get thrown a bit
in a blender
and then they resort now they behave
completely independently
so you've got this organism that has a
octoploid history but it's highly
diploidized so it behaves just like
arabidopsis for all practical purposes
so this is a was a really powerful uh
aspect for us because we have diploid
genetics
but octopoid genomics if that makes
sense
so one one of the things the first
things we did to
to start to prepare to build this
the axiom arrays i'm going to talk about
was
to resequence a large panel of
of domesticated and wild individuals and
we found
very very high levels of nucleotide
diversity across the genome
that's what i'm showing in this slide so
this is one of the chromosomes here
at the bottom mark d
and you can see that there's different
populations being represented
and that one of the populations has less
diversity than the others
that happens to be the university of
california davis breeding population
and we've discovered through this
process that it has less diversity
than the other populations that factors
in to how we design the array also which
is partly why i'm sharing that
now we see some chromosomes where it's
not as pronounced so this heavy line
here at the bottom is
a reduction of variation but what we
found in strawberry globally
is that the alleles that came in from
the wild
which is represented here in this euler
diagram
is that the alleles have been preserved
so the alleles came in from the wild
and they've been largely preserved
through the domestication process
it's really a fascinating uh uh
thing that's happened in strawberry and
there's a lot of reasons for it
so we have extensive uh nucleotide
diversity
and this played a huge role in our
ability to
develop sub-genome-specific assays
throughout the genome
i hope you'll find the results for the
axiom array to be uh
interesting and exciting before i go
there
i'll tell you what we did in parallel
with this and
again this is a bit of an eye chart
there's a lot of detail but i i want you
to take away
one idea one message here
we hold genome shotgun sequence progeny
in a in a
giant mapping population in fact in the
parents
are the ones are the are the two genomes
we've sequenced
and what what this allowed us to do was
to understand how well we could take
next generation
sequencing data so paired in 150 base
pair reads
and anchor them to the genome and so
what you see here
is the physical map versus the genetic
map and we get this beautiful
collinearity
we were able to populate the 5000 bins
in across the genome with about 1.9
million
dna variants so plenty of dna variants
and they're found throughout the genome
part of what we discovered is that in
domesticated populations there have been
selective
sweeps on chromosomes and there are
regions of the genome that are devoid of
markers
so when we started developing the axiom
array we had this advantage of knowing
that not not only could we tell the four
subgenomes apart
but we could find dna variants
throughout the genome
and what was key there is that we were
able to use the uh
wild species as the anchor because if we
had used domesticated populations
we would have been missing big uh
stretches haploblocks
in the in the genome for the designing
of arrays and
and and developing the uh information to
develop the arrays
so i've mentioned the uh istraw 90 snip
ray
which was the first one developed for
strawberry i didn't have anything to do
with it
nala basil and colleagues uh did that
and
uh i think that's that array that axiom
raised had
a tremendous impact we used it a lot in
the first two years
of our uh tenure at uc davis
and it was based on this first diploid
genome that was published for woodland
strawberry
and what we discovered is that
that array it had tremendous utility so
don't misunderstand me but
it was the distribution of probes was
uneven
and none of the probe sequences could be
anchored to our new octopoid genome
the reason for that was they were short
sequences based on this diploid and they
just didn't map
unambiguously so we went in
with an entire new process
through our whole genome shotgun
sequencing we did around a hundred
individuals
and that included fergari on anasa which
is the domesticated
and then fragaria chiloensis and
fragaria virginiana which are these wild
parents
and on the right here what you're seeing
is the 28 chromosomes and these are just
distribution plots
uh showing where uh michael
laid down probe sequences uh for this
design
process with affymetrix now how this
worked was
we did a bunch of in by in-house
bioinformatics the
the mapping i showed you earlier and and
learning and we were providing sequences
to the
team at uh that was building the axiom
array
and and they also then applied analyses
and gave us back scores
and i think that was a really great
partnership because between the two
bioinformatics teams
we ended up with uh with a really
excellent design
it was a little nerve-racking when we
were doing this because we were
designing this
and you know of course bioinformatically
and then sending the design off
and we that those were anxious moments
for us will this how will this go for us
so we started with the 850 k snip array
tremendous um exciting thing for us
because we laid probes down every 0.1
of of the genome uh and and
uh just waited for the data to come back
and one of the very first things we did
was use that data
to look at population structure and i'll
just cut right to the chase of what
happened now the 850
000 snips we easily got about a half a
million
that were really strongly co-dominant
the other 400 000 or so were were fine
too there were several that
had no minor allele homozygotes that
type of thing
so we really focused in on that half a
million it was way more than we really
needed
for most of our applications but as the
studies came together we we knew a lot
about population structure
and we found that we got excellent
concordance
from the array to whole genome shotgun
sequencing patterns of diversity
so that i i don't want to go through the
the whole story of what's happening in
these
patterns of diversity it was just really
a message of saying
that one concern people always have
about
array technology is a snip ascertainment
bias
and we certainly have it we design the
array to
capture alleles that were found in the
global domesticated population
uh but what we see is a really
uh powerful tool to uh
tell the story of domestication of
strawberry and to navigate
uh through that complex genome the other
thing that's been incredibly powerful
for us in in
is building genetic maps and this is
published the
the arrays actually are published in
this paper we built two the 50k and the
850k
and and so we've used those in
combination with
some of the other approaches we talked
about i talked about
to build genetic maps and one of our
discoveries
was that these wild species that came
together
they're completely co-linear genomes so
they
the the genes can flow freely among
these there's eight different subspecies
they can flow freely and what was really
tremendously exciting and fun for us is
that
once we we got the arrays and got and we
we designed the 50k
array we sent mapping populations off
and i think was
two weeks three weeks we had our data
back extremely low
genotyping error you know the the story
of this
if you've been using axiom arrays very
low genotyping errors uh
highly reliable it was just the speed
with which
we could answer questions and address
problems was was fantastic
so that that gives you really the
foundation of
you know why we build a raise over the
last five years uh
you know there was the eye straw array
we we built these two
every probe we put on here except for a
small set from the eye straw
axiom array is anchored to this octopoid
reference
and just to let you know we've just
rebuilt we've just built phase genomes
for strawberry
and we've remapped everything to those
they're they're really fantastic
improvements even over the first genome
and we've got the arrays re-anchored
back on them so we're still using those
extensively and have some more
applications that that we'll be
pursuing well you know why'd we do this
strawberry is in a globally
is in a really significant transition
period
uh the chemical control measures that
have been so important to enabling
growers
to reliably produce fruit have changed
dramatically in the last decade
and diseases are becoming
more and more problematic the
alternatives that have been available to
them
have been limited so one of our most
important missions the last five years
has been to
to dive in to uh disease resistance
genetics and strawberry and this
illustrates one of our very first
discoveries it actually was
achieved with with the eye straw array
and then as we built the genome and got
the new arrays we've
added on to that substantially but we
found uh
really the first resistance gene ever
discovered in strawberry which may sound
strange
was a few serum welt resistance gene and
we did that with
uh with aximerase
to kind of segue where that's gone we've
discovered many others since then
and we've been screening
uh diverse material from around the
globe
this is a map of where all the materials
coming from some of it's wild
some of it is domesticated and trying to
identify sources of resistance to
uh virulent races of of this pathogen
that are found outside california
it's it's remarkable we're in the middle
of a pandemic
and one of our concerns is that
we found resistance to the pathogen
race that's found in california but the
concern is the way
plants are moving around the world that
that these
other virulent races will appear and we
know
uh sadly from our recent experience in
with kovid that this can happen in in
the blink of an eye
so the good news there is again array
technology has been hugely important
this pattern of diversity we're showing
here is all based on the array
technology
the diversity we've sampled across the
globe
and this is just a heat map showing the
the resistant susceptible genotypes we
found
and the good news is we found more
sources of resistance than we can
possibly
tackle in any been a career time and
and we've done it very very rapidly
through four genetic approaches with
ray-based genotyping now
the arrays are fantastic but what we
need to be able to do
is to apply the discovered loci in
in a in a breeding
in a breeding situation so what we've
done
is gone in and used the the uh
arrays to pinpoint loci using
genome-wide association mapping
and other approaches and this just shows
that we've
found the location at the top of one of
the chromosomes
of this resistance gene it turns out
that that we found
five other genes in that region through
independent sources
and you can see the range of resistance
here this is a
extremely high g wasp pink uh
very significant locus it's allowed us
to pinpoint
we think we have the actual gene but
we've been using cast markers which is a
lgc technology that's widely used
to develop individual assays off of the
array validated snips and
we've had a tremendous amount of
conversion success i'd say
well over 90 percent success uh
successful conversion of array to to
casp
uh assays and we're using these now to
select
materials in uh early generations uh
that we advance so that we're uh
only moving forward resistant materials
it's a very common
uh genomic form a breeding
approach and problem that is used in
wheat and tomato and
many other species we're just catching
up in strawberry and uh
and and really bring this technology
forward
the other type of application that's
really important
for us is uh genomic prediction and i've
talked
quite a lot quite a lot with the team
about that but we have other diseases
that turn out to be
incredibly complex like verticillium
weld and this just shows a
resistant individual the most resistant
individual we found
out of global collection and then a
susceptible uh individual there on the
right
but this this requires a completely
different approach genomic prediction or
genomic selection
and again the axiomar rate comes into
play here
this just shows the distribution of
probes across the genome
so what we know is that with this array
technology
we have the uh genome covered end to end
that was really important to us we don't
want to leave any chromosome arms off or
any regions
and we we feel really good that we've
got excellent coverage
across the genome so the general process
is we form a population which call a
training population
this case it was only 400 individuals
we genotype them with the axiom array
build a genetic relationship matrix
which is what you see here
and this is just a key saying that
there's different
back genetic backgrounds that went into
this and
we again sample diversity across the
globe
our goal here was uh really two-fold
when we went into this we had no idea
that there wouldn't be uh gene for gene
resistance
as we saw for fusarium weld uh and what
we learned is that there does not appear
to be
classic gene for gene resistance so
we're into this complex
resistance uh problem uh i'm trying to
think of some analogies here
you know in the in the world of human
diseases
there are a lot of human diseases that
are extremely complex and for which the
cause of loci
haven't been um identified and i think
you see in in the
in the human world now uh human genetics
world
uh quite a lot of work to use genomic
prediction of
approaches to uh identifying
risk factors or identifying in our case
susceptible resistant individuals from
their dna fingerprint as opposed to
their
actual disease reaction
this slide captures the
the essence of what we're doing there
and what we what we've done this paper
is just coming out next week i think but
we did this
multi-year study and what this shows is
the actual observed phenotypes here on
this axis
you we can just look at any at this
bottom group here
and uh we have two years of studying in
the combined so
even looking at one of these plots what
these are
as we use the observed phenotype and the
fingerprint
to get a predicted value and you can see
it it's shrunk down a bit
our main goal is to get this lower end
of the curve here
where the resistant individuals exist
and again
with the array fingerprinting was very
fast we got the data back quickly
uh the hard part of this experiment
wasn't genotyping once that
was that technology was developed the
hard part was getting the phenotypic
data and doing the statistical analyses
but what we've learned from this is that
this this approach works extremely well
in strawberry we have very high uh
reproducibility
we we say high heritability and uh
and we get excellent um prediction
accuracies
so those are the the fusarium and the
verticillium stories are
at opposite ends of the spectrum in
terms of genetic complexity
but yet we've used the same genotyping
technology to get answers just simply
different paths
forward with that so i'll segue in this
is really a cartoon more than anything
this is what our beautiful nurseries
look like every year
here in winters california it's very
close to davis
uh we screen twelve thousand to twenty
thousand um
seedlings a year selecting for multiple
traits
uh yield fruit quality
disease resistance the
genome itself and the tools that the
genome enabled
put us in a position to apply mark
assisted selection
as we did in in the fusarium case i
showed you
or genomic selection as in the
verticillium welt case
uh so what we're trying to do now is
translate these academic studies
and proof of concept studies into
um action in a real breeding program
and so i said earlier earlier in the in
the talk that
you know i inherited 90 years of
breeding history
uh the university and and and the people
in the state that are involved in
agriculture want this program to
continue for many years
and what we've done is overlaid now
you know the the genomic knowledge and
information to help drive
progress in developing better cultivars
i'm putting this out here because we
don't want to continue to do this
we want to be able to select on a bench
from seedling leaf samples that we
quickly genotype so that what we put out
in the field are all the individuals
that are predicted to carry
the genes that we want and need to
protect this crop from diseases or to
deliver
the high quality or high yield so that's
that's
the technical challenge we have in front
of us
and i i think the real issue for us now
is that the rays have have still have a
significant place for us in our genetics
work and
many studies that are going forward uh
we
we are having difficulty uh
applying it on the kind of scale i'm
showing an industrial scale because we
need to get to
something that is much more inexpensive
um the interesting thing for us is that
we have cast marker technology on one
end which works for marx
selection but we need whole genome
solutions and we need a whole
genome solution a single tube solution
because when we germinate seeds in in
june
we have about a four week window before
we're getting ready to transplant
so four to eight weeks so we need to get
the dna out get the genotypes back
make this and then perform analyses and
make decisions
and that's a fairly typical uh
problem whether you're looking at maize
breeding or soybean breeding
or strawberry breeding um and so we're
now
in the process where i really can't talk
about it today because i'm working with
a couple of
of partners and we we don't have our
pilot studies
totally finished yet but we're looking
at middle density solutions
five thousand two to five thousand loci
uh that we can use to apply to this kind
of setting
this is something that uh in i've had
large conversations with a group at
cornell
uh and worked with uh large teams that
are trying to solve this same problem
in many crops and and so i think there's
a
a really important gap or whole uh
in in this sort of applied agricultural
genomics area
and people are filling it with different
approaches some people been using
genotyping by sequencing uh we've used
it
in strawberry it works but it's not
quite the right solution for us
so i hope that that'll inspire you and
others to
develop technologies for this middle
density because we we really urgently
need solutions that we can afford to
apply on a large scale um
i i just need to say that i have
had amazing people in my lab the last
five years students and postdocs
technical people wonderful colleagues
and the support of
many collaborators across the u.s and
world
and also the industry and have
have had probably one of the most
enjoyable times in my own career here
uh in in plant breeding and uh
can tell you that the uh axiom arrays
have played a huge role
in the rapid success of of a lot of our
four genetics work
so that i'll close my seminar and
thank you very much for the opportunity
to talk to you today